you like this this is the whole new
office back at home I'm still vlogging
in Sacramento so me yes now if you don't
know already growing up I was a huge
Kanye West man but what they can't do is
really kiss me look at me college
dropout make my stretchin and I heard
him saying graduation well well the
dudes mixtape to his first three solid
albums where the soundtrack to my life
now four years ago before he started to
go crazy and I saw Kanye West I would
have done this [ __ ] that girls do when
they see their man crush that's not a
little bit looks like an always but
recently I found out as I really do keep
up with celebrity whereabouts the Kanye
West is putting out a new clothing line
a little later the [ __ ] but I saw
recently so [ __ ] it now I support
anybody and their positive passions
especially kinda late was because he
said that he wanted to take his clothing
line and push it beyond just Street and
urban where he wanted to show us that in
his words you can't marginalize and tell
them as a black male hip-hop artist what
clothes he can and can't create and I
love that message so I saw the [ __ ] he
put out now I understand that everybody
has a different case for clothes and I'm
the same for my personal taste it looks
like garbage tell me what your clothing
lines would lie everybody the screen
from the matrix [ __ ] everybody on the
runway look like they were from the
Great Depression
look at this sweater this makes when
she's got a button a tornado and he lost
and once again I realize that everybody
has a different item things but what I'm
going to talk about right now is how
much that [ __ ] cost bring your what
dragon skin [ __ ] if you are gonna try
to be a hundred and twenty dollars for a
plain white t-shirt that [ __ ] better
have been made from the finest hairs
from a unicorn but talk about
the fan and your people I kept kidding
the question that was an interview in
sweat in the morning where you said you
wanted your clothes line to be
accessible and affordable to everybody
everywhere well [ __ ] gonna buy $3,000
the best [ __ ] stop bullets and
flamethrowers look at this [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says you are
wearing a garbage bag I'm just saying
right now eternity of clothes you said
you do a new [ __ ]
I don't think so he's already been done
maybe you've heard of it The Walking
Dead your clothes look post-apocalyptic
as [ __ ] listen I would have to go
through a famine and a Japanese nightbot
to think that your clothes was
acceptable to wear don't even get me
started on the DeeZee boots coming that
[ __ ] don't look like pick machine mail
us people get to hide about island
because it's a rare car and just because
a trendsetter does it doesn't mean you
have to like it
I don't just dislike [ __ ] just because
it's popular that's awful the [ __ ]
dumbest thing on earth but I don't think
something looks good if you don't think
something looks good you don't have to
like it kinda if you ever see this video
look me in the eye right now and tell me
you did not design your shoe after an
elephant's foot listen I know that
clothing is hard and I'm not knocking
the man's hustle he's a legend in the
making but don't be coming up but we can
say [ __ ] mind if y'all don't like my
[ __ ] you can't see the future [ __ ] and
you can Miss Cleo that's the boldest
statement I've ever heard of my life how
is the basis of your argument going to
be superpowers you're [ __ ] right about
one thing I can be the future but even
Miss Cleo saying it's not doing the
tarot cards it's about the words to make
an action I've ever done oh you like
that video make sure you guys leave more
topics for me to talk about this I will
just be vlogging up the butthole I still
don't know what's gonna make Wednesday's
about quite yet but I'm thinking about
it thinking about it give me more topics
give me more suggestions I am here for
you but yes you guys I will see you guys
every Wednesday and every Sunday I was a
little
so I could bring out a video but I still
brought it out on Wednesday so you'll at
least get once a week so stop being
greedy [ __ ] love you
now I support anybody and their positive
passions especially funny was because
he's